welcome back man man it feels so good to
be back in the u.s. yeah Wow you know
just two and a half months of
backpacking all around the world sounds
amazing
yeah you know I was just like just
culture shock culture shock you know I'm
just like learning about all these
different cultures and countries I'm I'm
just a changed man crazy
well hey you must be hungry let some
starving it's crazy that we're about to
have dinner because I'm so used to Nick
attack what time that like it's normally
breakfast Oh
Nicaragua you were down there yeah
Nicaragua it was just beautiful I highly
recommend it okay cool yeah oh look at
this they have that linguini with the
meat the ball is I wonder how that's
gonna hold up to the one in Italy you
know is that how they said linguini with
meatballs oh yeah yeah you know after
spending three and a half days in Italy
just start picking up you know Italian
its linguini with the meat the bony
yeah I didn't know egg because that
actually sounds like a little offensive
I don't think it's offensive I think I'm
doing the culture a service by
pronouncing the food the way it's
supposed to be pronounced wow this place
has everything they even have full foul
chicken yeah that's actually pronounced
going about chicken Chinese so oh you
been to China too I mean I haven't but
but you know what I've had all this
stuff you know I might just get some
greasy American food yeah I'll just go
with America look right here
or ALJ's mmm fellers delectable exact
that's not how we say grilled cheese
what am I gonna wash it down with maybe
a Sam Adams bear there's a warder mmm
I'm gonna go for the PAP really you're
over in the Midwest you yeah I had a
layover in venusaur laughs been a couple
hours Minnesota you met me nice Ord
Minnesota I mean Isolde Minnesota
Minnesota Minnesota Minnesota Zach I
think you're being kind of an [ __ ]
[ __ ] what even is that accent you
know you have an accent you have a
California accent comes out sometimes
you know what Zach I'm done with this
conversation I'm gonna order excuse me
yeah we'll take two cool salads please
thank you very much